hallo wie geht's euch mir geht's gut
danke der Nachfrage
keiner hat gefragt dreimal dürfte raten
wo ich gerade hinfahre richtig zum
Bahnhof und dreimal durch die raten wenn
ich hier abhole auch wieder richtig
Steffi ich hole Sandra vom Bahnhof ab
weil sie heute in Köln ist das liegt
relativ nach und sie ist in Köln weil
Podcast wir nehmen heute
selbstverständlich wieder neue
lol das kann leider mit dem E-Scooter
gebaut aber gut nee Sandra kommt auf
jeden Fall nach Köln weil wir neue
Folgen von unserem Podcast aufnehmen und
ich hole die jetzt erstmal kurz ab
steigt doch einfach ein Digger
wie lecker Schokobons und jule hat ja
noch ein Brot geschmiert und
selbstverständlich gebracht ich hatte
kein Kölsch mehr ich habe noch
Krombacher ist okay
nein
du kannst so schön
[Musik]
muss man Leute einfach stumpf anlächeln
die gucken gerne mal richtig [ __ ]
anfangen
ziemlich abstoßend junge es ist so
peinlich laufe bei nur so
Geschäftsmenschen rum weil hier ist
irgendwie Bankenviertel da vorne jetzt
Sandra hier habt ihr das juckt mich
irgendein feuchten Furz Alter ich bin eh
viel geiler als die
Leute Alter
hier nein
wir haben nämlich meine aufnahmezimmer
so ein bisschen umgeräumt also sieht
jetzt bisschen Cleaner aus ein Teppich
ist raus hier Sandra hey Leute was ist
deine Meinung auch aus
Sandra wir wollen den einfach nur im
Keller bringen baut die hier so eine
Rutsche
[Musik]
einfach im Keller bringen
so danke Sandra
wir nehmen jetzt erstmal Podcast auf
hallo und herzlich Willkommen meine
Damen und Herren seine neue Folge Dick
und Doof mit Luca und
Digger ich kann eigentlich gar nicht
mehr erreichen dicker komm direkt
warte
dann kam Chris also ein Kollege von mir
an wir haben im Podcast über dich
geredet wegen Sommer
nimmt jetzt auf jeden Fall gleich eine
Bahn zurück wieder nach Hause nach
Bielefeld und ich hole jetzt ein Kumpel
ab deswegen werde ich dann noch nicht
mehr sehen tschüss
immer mit der Ruhe okay ich finde es so
ein Mensch den muss man immer Abholen
der Schatz nicht dass er allein zu einem
kommt Tag Freunde
ich dachte Sandra wäre abgecheckt wieso
sitzt sie jetzt denn hier dann noch wir
gehen jetzt was essen essen mit den
Jungs
zum ersten Mal zum E-Scooter hier durch
Köln voll langsam aus meine Damen und
Herren wir gehen jetzt noch raus in eine
Bar oder irgendwo anders hin aber an der
Stelle würde ich auf jeden Fall den
heutigen Block erstmal beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne Daumen hoch
da das Chris
was machst du ich wollte eigentlich
gerade
leider vielleicht noch Tschüss sagen im
Block
[Musik]
die Leute noch gar nicht mitbekommen
aber der Zug hat irgendwie technische
Probleme dann ist sie da anderthalb
Stunden stecken geblieben ist jetzt
wieder zurück nach Köln gefahren und
pennt jetzt hier also keine Ahnung
tschüss
[Musik]